[Music]
it's midterm elections in el salvador
this year many people are expected to
vote along party lines
and the new ideas party led by el
salvador's president naib bouquet
is a favorite to win president pukele is
very popular among voters and even
though the president is not on the
ballot
the logic among many here seems to be
that a vote for the president's party
is a vote to support the president's
national agenda
it's important for us to vote i think
president bukele
is very capable he has shown us that he
can make our country succeed
everyone trusts him we know he's going
to do good
last november president bukela's
approval rating was 96 percent
according to a gallup poll and
congressional candidates are hoping to
ride on the coattails of that popularity
and seize a congressional majority for
the president's party
some analysts however say controlling a
majority of seats in the salvadoran
congress
would further consolidate the powers of
the presidency
a slippery slope toward the politics of
the 1970s and 80s
when the president held absolute power
if you listen to the propaganda from the
new ideas party the only thing they're
proposing
is to help the president govern they'll
exist only to carry out the interests of
the president
they are offering no other pragmatic
legislative purpose
since becoming president in 2019
nadipuquel's popularity has only grown
much of this is due to the success of
his government's anti-violence
initiative
which cut homicides in the country by
almost half
however buchela has also clashed with
political opponents
and has been criticized by human rights
groups who have accused him of having an
authoritarian streak
pointing to the treatment of gang
members in the nation's prisons
and last year bugele drew harsh
criticism after he brought
armed soldiers into el salvador's
national congress building to pressure
lawmakers into approving
a new security law
is someone who does not respect the rule
of law he disrespects opponents
disrespects the national and
international press and disrespects
every person who has the courage to
oppose him
some political observers say sunday's
municipal and congressional elections
could prove consequential for the future
of el salvador's democracy
opinion polls project the president's
new ideas party
will win between 43 and 56 of the 84
seeds up for grabs
in el salvador's congress manuel rapalo
al jazeera